which tablet is basically the best  gaming tablet in 2022 let's jump right  into it the massive display on the tab  is awesome but in some of the games the  actual display was so big that i don't  know the scaling or something wasn't as  good so the display isn't as high  quality and of course you have the pwm  lines that could annoy some people and  also the speakers on the ipad pro were  better if you're okay with just playing  at  fps then the tab is fine for most games  you get the bigger display which is very  nice but in genshin it couldn't even  handle a solid 60 it went down to 40  many times for some reason if you want  the best fps i mean like almost all of  those games that we played gave us a 120  fps option on the ipad pro that is  absolutely amazing so with all of that  said  i'm honestly going to give the win to  the ipad pro it is still the best gaming  tablet out there